bismillah alhamdulillah assalamualaikum
greetings of peace my brothers and
sisters it is with great love and
genuine concern that I'm sharing with
you some extremely important points that
I really want you to think about for
those who are not establishing salah the
prayer in their lives in another video
I've discussed the tremendous benefits
of establishing prayer but here we'll be
going over some extremely important
points to think over when a person
doesn't pray or abandons the salat
prayer in their life altogether point
number one this is just plain and simple
you are disobeying your Creator look in
the Quran which is the verbatim word of
God Almighty Allah chapter 86 verse 6
Allah the Almighty Creator is saying oh
mankind what has deceived you concerning
your Lord the most gracious think about
the thing or things brothers and sisters
that you have put between you and your
Lord that have deceived you when the
whole purpose of your very existence is
to worship God Almighty Allah yet you
choose to disobey your Creator Allah
wants you to ponder over these verses
this one is in chapter 19 verse 59 to 60
of the Quran where he says then there
has succeeded them a generation who have
given up prayer and followed their
desires
so they will be thrown into the Hellfire
except those who repent and believe and
work righteousness the mercy of Allah
his door is always open you just got to
turn back humble yourself and repent to
him alone and start establishing the
commandments of Allah and one of the
most important ones is the Salah prayer
brothers and sisters ponder over this
ayah in the Quran chapter 74 verse 42 to
43 where God Almighty Allah is
describing a scene in the future where
the people of the Hellfire will be asked
what has caused you to enter Jahannam
the Hellfire they will say we were not
of those who used to pray
point number two you are being an
extremist extremely ungrateful to your
Creator if someone gave you a dollar or
bought you a cup of coffee gave you a
gift you'd at least say thank you but
God Almighty Allah is giving you air and
water eyes and ear countless upon
countless of priceless blessings too
many to enumerate and by refusing your
creator's invitation to establish this
close relationship with him it's the
ultimate ingratitude Allah created you
brothers and sisters and gave you
everything as mentioned in the Quran
ayah 67 verse 23 where Allah says it is
he who created you and endowed you
hearing and seeing in hearts little are
you grateful did you know that the last
and final messenger sent to mankind
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him his feet would swell up because
he would stand in prayer for long
periods of time and when asked about
this he replied should I not be a
grateful servant of my lord point number
3 you are being an extremist again
extremely lazy what excuses will you
give your Creator the creator of the
heavens and the earth hey the one on
judgement day who will judge you the one
who blessed you with twenty-four hours
in a day yet only asked you to spend 25
to 30 minutes per prayer that split up
into five daily breaks five ten fifteen
twenty twenty-five and you can't take a
break to thank him to be grateful to him
to pray to him point number four you'll
end up being miserable at the end Allah
says in the Quran chapter 21 24th onward
and whoever turns away from my
remembrance indeed for him is a life of
hardship
and I will raise him up on the Day of
Resurrection blind and he'll say my lord
why have you raised me up blind when I
was able to see Allah will say didn't my
signs come to you and you disregarded
them and thus well you this day be
forgotten
so because we were blind to his signs
signals the advice the warnings the love
that was sent your way you chose to be
blind the same way you'll be resurrected
blind on the day of judgment it's very
scary brothers and sisters point number
five you are only harming yourself you
seem to forget that Allah doesn't need
your prayers or anything from anyone it
is you that stands in need of his mercy
we need him Allah doesn't need anyone
Allah says in the Quran give thanks to
Allah and whoever gives thanks it is
only for his own Souls good and whoever
is ungrateful surely God Almighty is
free of all needs Allah is free of all
needs brothers and sister worthy of all
praise this is in chapter 31 verse 12 of
the quran point number 6 you are
flirting with disbelief the majority of
scholars in islam hold the opinion that
the people that don't pray they're
flirting with disbelief there are verge
of being disbelievers according to
following hadith from the messenger
prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him see we have the Quran and the
Sunnah the one who explains the Quran is
the last and final messenger problem
Hama peace and blessings be upon him the
same way Jesus he went and explained he
was given the instructions about the
injeel and moses the Toraja and muhammad
is the last final messenger so we have
his hadith authentically narrated he
said the Covenant between that would
distinguishes us and them the believer
and the one who doesn't believe is the
prayer and whoever neglects it has
disbelieved and additionally the
prophets companions those who knew him
the best knew this deen islam the best
they didn't consider anything an act of
disbelief or abandoning any other
injunction disbelief except the
abandonment of Salah
because look a Muslim is one who submits
to the will of Allah to the Creator to
Allah so if you're not submitting to
Allah who are you submitting to your
desires to your nest to Shaitaan my
brothers and sisters these are reminders
that are put out there out of the love
but I can't love you more than your
Creator loves you please I genuinely
sincerely ask you don't lose this
opportunity while we are alive to have a
wonderful loving relationship with your
Creator
remember on his terms not yours before
death reaches us then it'll be too late
thank you once again thank you so much
for listening and sharing
you